je suis producteur de
avant tout je suis
amoureux de musique puisque en fait je
n'ai pas toujours été producteur de
musique électronique
quand j'étais petit par exemple dans mes
premières années je me souviens avoir
été bercé au son des rolling stones ce
par mes parents très différents donc
après je me suis mis à la guitare à 13
ans c'est mon premier instrument et donc
je me se tourner vers des styles
musicaux qui était plutôt près du rock
du jazz du blues de la soul et j'ai
commencé à peu près le même âge aussi à
acquérir mes premiers disques par mes
propres moyens souvent de seconde main
en brocante que ça soit décédé ou des
vinyles des vinyles actuellement je
pense que j'en ai environ un peu plus de
200 ma bibliothèque numérique par contre
va doit plutôt se tourner autour des 25
mille morceaux donc c'est peut-être
beaucoup je vais pas trop en parler mais
justement bibliothèque numérique
le choc culturel que j'ai eu avec la
musique c'est fait par internet comme un
avis de nombreux gens de ma génération
c'est en arrivant au lycée que internet
le haut débit est arrivé ou au foyer
familial
et c'est à ce moment là en fait où j'ai
été un peu poussé hors de ma zone de
confort par tout ce que je pouvais
ingurgiter justement sur le réseau en
soi donc tout ce qui était rock
psychédélique blues et cetera j'ai
commencé à délaisser
ceci pour m'intéresser à d'autres genres
musicaux d'autres styles et d'autres
aires géographiques
ce qui m'a permis en fait de voyager par
exemple au japon au brésil en afrique
sans quitter mon canapé bien entendu
mais le vrai choc
le vrai choc culturel que j'ai eu c'est
la rencontre avec les musiques
électroniques
je dis bien les musiques électroniques
au pluriel en réalité puisque vous
l'imaginez c'est un genre constitué
d'énormément de sous genres et
énormément d'autres arborescence c'est
quelque chose qui a tout de même 30 35
ans dans sa forme actuelle mais qui
datent d'après la seconde guerre
mondiale il faut le savoir mais donc ce
choc avec la musique électronique c'est
pas un choc de genre c'est un choc de
moyens c'est un choc de production c'est
qu'en fait j'ai réalisé que ce que je
faisais avec mon groupe je pouvais faire
tout seul et mieux puisque pas de
batailles d'ego et c est donc c'est une
nouvelle manière de créer de la musique
par soi même on doit une somme d'homme
orchestre donc finalement je me suis
doté d'un ordinateur
ce n'est pas le même mais un ordinateur
de petit contrôleur dans ce dans ce
genre si et voilà j'ai fait mes
premières mais problème mes premières
armes comme ça et je pense avoir au
moins 7 ans d'expérience sur un logiciel
de musique assistée par ordinateur en
soi donc il ya deux principes
fondamentaux dans les logiques
electronics est la synthèse sonore d'un
côté le fait en fait de transformer un
signal électrique au début en un son
amplifié et je ne vais pas trop en
parler soir et le sampling dont vraiment
je vais me focaliser sur le sampling ce
soir le fait de réutiliser un
enregistrement sur n'importe quel
support bande magnétique cd vinyles et
c'est un enregistrement déjà pré
existants dans une propres compositions
personnelles en soit grâce à ces deux
procédés j'ai réalisé qu'on pouvait
s'extirper de la théorie musicale des
carcans de la musique traditionnelle
telle qu'on l'a telle qu'on la conçoit
encore pour d'autres genres musicaux et
en fait que la création devenir
accessible à n'importe qui du moment
qu'on a de l'imagination et qu'on y met
un peu de moi il ya beaucoup de temps
aussi
j'ai mis du temps et en fait vos deux
seuls bri deviennent l'oreille il faut
que ça sonne juste et votre imagination
comme je le dis jusqu'où irez voilà donc
en soi le sampling
si vous voulez c'est un procédé dont qui
est né à la moitié du siècle environ en
soit les premiers les premiers à avoir
utilisé ce système de récupération
ça s'est fait via la musique savante par
exemple pierre schaeffer qui est plus ou
moins de théoriciens de la musique
concrète
utilisez déjà le travail de deux le
travail sur les bandes
en 1948 il me semble par la suite c'est
un
[Musique]
bien plus connue qui a popularisé ce
procédé c'est les beatles les beatles
dès la fin des années 60 en pleine
révolution psychédélique ont amené le
sample dans la pop music
mais là où je veux en venir c'est le
semble dans sa version moderne dans sa
réutilisation moderne est véritablement
né au début des années 1970 dans le
bronx à new york via le mouvement hip
hop
en fait pour les besoins des danseurs
des b-boys débreaker les dj de hip hop
acheter deux fois le même disque à
l'identique et enchaîner en fait le
passage instrumental le break
l'enchaîner de manière infinie en
recalant le en recalant le disque comme
ça bien entendu le procédé a clairement
évolué depuis
la preuve mais ce sont les bases en fait
de cette révolution musicale
ensuite dans les années 80 le sampling
s'est répandu dans la pop dans la new
wave dans énormément de styles musicaux
très en vogue à ce moment là mais c'est
surtout la révolution technologique est
vraiment arrivé dans les années 90 avec
d'un côté la house de chicago et la
techno de détroit donc voilà deux villes
il ya diamétralement opposées mais
partageant le même les mêmes moyens de
production si vous voulez je vais
justement vous parlez de sampling et
vous faire quelques exemples si tout
fonctionne comme il le faut en soi je
vous ai choisi d des éléments très connu
justement pour essayer de raviver
certains souvenirs mais également de
vous faire un choc en vous montrant les
morceaux d'origine
voilà donc vous connaissez peut-être
stardust un morceau un groupe de la
housse français qui a fait un morceau
s'appelant music sounds better with you
en 1998 qui ressemble à ceci
[Musique]
voilà je ne laisse pas plus longtemps je
pense que vous avez sans doute reconnu
est ce que si je vous parle de chaka
khan une chanteuse de disco ça vous
avoir quelque chose peut-être pas en
1981 elle a sorti un morceau qui
s'appelle feuilleton faillite ressemble
à ceci voilà tout est dedans on a
également un autre morceau moi qui a qui
mémorielle mans en fait a vraiment
influencé mon enfance je m'en souviens
années quatre-vingt dix-huit pareil ces
morceaux de fatboy slim artistes de
musique électronique anglais right here
right now que voici
[Musique]
je pense que vous l'avez tous entendu
saviez-vous en fait que les deux
mélodies que l'on entend dans ce petit
extrait venait d'un groupe se nommant ce
james gang qui est un groupe en fait de
rock américain
enfin les 78 années 70 et donc le son
origine elle date de 1970 le voici
[Musique]
effectivement
on a également un autre passage ici
[Musique]
voilà donc pour ces petits exemples
connus certains simple néanmoins sont
devenus littéralement légendaire du
moins dans le milieu que je côtoie celui
de la production électronique
il ya pareillement il ya par exemple un
simple on appelle le amène break qui en
fait un break de batteries qui date de
1969 qui provient d'un morceau ce moment
amène brava et qui vient du nom qui a
été fait par le groupe the wiz de
winston tubman
le voici ce break peut-être que vous en
douter mais ce break en fête a permis
l'émancipation du hip hop d'une part
quand il a été ralenti et d'une autre
part il a il a permis la création de
genres musicaux surtout électronique
comme la jungle qui a accéléré de
manière assez exacerber cette cette
ligne de batteries voici la version
ralentie dans le groupe nda value et un
groupe de gangsta rap californien et
dans sa version clairement accéléré dans
la bo de pi film de darren aronofsky
signer à ce que vous connaissez très
certainement
[Musique]
c'est radicalement de choses on est
d'accord mais voilà je vous ai montré
des manières de simples et des choses
c'est quelque chose qui était très
répandu dans les années 90 au début des
années 2000 depuis les moyens
technologiques ont clairement changé et
donc chacun en fait peut trouver une
sorte de manière on comment dire
personnel de manière un peu propres à
lui de sampler tous et tous ces bruits
du commun tous ces bruits musicaux tous
ses disques et moi justement j'ai choisi
de sampler ma collection et j'ai choisi
également de samples et quelques bruits
quelques bruits de la vie de tous les
jours par exemple je me trouve ici je
veux faire cette petite démonstration
je me suis dit pour faire une rythmique
peut-être qu'on pourrait prendre par
exemple des bruits de la vie quotidienne
comme imaginons c'est une portière de
voiture qui se ferme
par contre j'ai un problème
pardon voilà ça c'est un druide porte de
voiture qui se referme on a deux là on
frappe sur de la tôle des bruits de
pièces pour les cymbales et le bruit
d'une caisse à outils qu'on pose sur le
sol en guise de percussion voilà donc
écoutez je vais essayer de créer un
rythme dans un premier temps grâce à
ceux-ci non voilà qui est mieux
un peu abrutissant quand même sans
mélodie vous trouvez donc iran pour
faire juste moins de mélodies je me suis
dotée ici de quelques sambre de ma
collection des morceaux en digital donc
et j'ai ce morceau par exemple de
radiohead qui traîne son disque dur
[Musique]
pas très guitare en ce moment c'est pas
trop mon truc donc par contre l'intro
plaît cette espèce de grincer textures
dans l'espèce de ligne de synthétiseurs
me plaît et donc en fait je vais en
tirer une mélodie revenons sur notre
petit rythme je peux faire tourner les
choses en groupe de manière assez assez
longue
et voilà donc on a notre petite mélodie
que j'ai enregistrées ici qui va tourner
en même temps que notre rythme
j'aimerais j'aimerais que le rythme est
un peu plus d'impact et pour ça par
exemple j'ai un morceau d'un groupe de
rock industriel allemand dont le nom est
plus ou moins imprononçable einstürzende
neubauten j'y suis arrivé c'est sans
doute la seule fois en fait la
particularité de ce groupe c'est de
jouer en live en concert avec du en
tapant réellement frappant en frottant
des vrais instruments de construction
des instruments de chant de chantier des
outils etc
donc voici le morceau assez austère
voilà on va servir tiède de la petites
percussions vous entendez au début je
vois si je rajoute mon rythme et je
rajoute ma mélodie
[Musique]
voilà donc j'ai également un dernier
petit bout de samples de ma bibliothèque
qu'il provient d'un du défunt musicien
japonais un musicien ambiante qui
s'appelait susumu yokota qui est une
sorte de grand apôtre de cette musique
au pays du soleil levant et donc voici
ce petit morceau parfait pour la
méditation
et donc voilà c'est relativement longe
le s p mais je vais me servir justement
de cette espèce de progression de volume
et ca pour créer une sorte d'anomalie
rythmique et mélodique un peu dans mon
morceau qui dans ma démo ceci dit qui va
justement créer une sorte de petit
décalage
donc on revient sur notre sur notre base
[Musique]
voilà j'en ai terminé avec cette petite
démonstration en soit vous l'aurez sans
doute compris le sampling c'est plus ou
moins procédé paradoxal dans le sens où
d'un côté c'est un art du détail
vraiment de l'infime détail d'infimes
particules sonore on règle des choses à
s'en briser sans doute les tympans tout
comme écouter des bruits de portières de
voitures qui se ferme toute la journée
sans doute mais ça peut également
justement être al'inverse totalement un
créateur d'anomalies en fait comme ce
que je viens de faire avec le dernier
simple c'est ce qui permet de rendre la
musique électronique pour moi plus
décalé peut-être avec certaines erreurs
mais certaines erreurs qui en fait
apporte un charme et qui sans doute au
final rendre cette musique électronique
qui est souvent considéré les termes que
j'entends souvent c'est justement boum
boum répétitives régler un peu comme une
horloge finalement comme le balancier
d'une horloge un peu redondante
en somme c'est ce qui pourrait permettre
à cette musique électronique de d'être
finalement plus humaine je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]